[Music]
so of course the emmys air Sunday on CBS
it'll be hosted by none other than
Steven Colbert that's him at the
official red carpet rollout you two
talked to the Late Show funny man about
what he's got up his sleeve note
he's also nominated and so he has plenty
to look forward to take a look yeah I'm
really excited because you know I was a
waiter for many years and what I really
wanted to do was work on New Year's Eve
so I could have something to do in case
I wasn't having a good time and the
great thing about hosting is that if you
lose your category you still have
something to do so it's just it's
wonderful I have busy work just to get
me through it in case I lives who should
be afraid in the audience who should be
afraid yes no one no one should be
afraid to play nice everyone everyone
it's we're all gonna be very nice to
each other be afraid of what they might
impale themselves on Emmys wings what do
you mean afraid and sometimes those
folks in the front row they get it oh
yeah yeah yeah Reese Witherspoon has it
coming okay I'm coming for your Reese
you've been warned Reese leave my load
here's what I want to know I wouldn't
know what Stephen Colbert is gonna do
about the food situation cuz lately you
know the Oscars they've been sitting
down food from the sky
those stars they hungry we do know that
there's gonna be an epic open to the
show and a close he promises singing
dancing and of course comedy we'll find
out when 8:00 we'll find out when the
Emmys air Sunday live on CBS
coast-to-coast 8:00 p.m. Eastern and
5:00 p.m. Pacific if you guys want to
watch it live you could tune in to CBS
on TV or stream on CBS all access and
thank you so much to our friends at Fiji
water be sure to keep it locked to you
T's Facebook page for all your Emmys
coverage we're gonna be coming to you
live immediately after the Emmys on
Sunday night to be breaking down the
night's biggest moment and then once
again on Monday morning to be talking
about all the best and worst fashion
[Music]
you